in the opening scene we are introduced
to a man named Dom Cobb I've seen this
movie a million times I don't remember
him having such a stupid name who wakes
up on a Shore in a state of extreme
fatigue he momentarily notices two
children playing in the sand before
losing Consciousness again shortly after
an armed guard discovers him and takes
him to a Grand Mansion owned by an old
wealthy Japanese businessman there he
has offered some food while the old man
claims that Cobb reminds him of a man he
met in a half-remembered dream stop
hitting on me old man the film then cuts
to a different scene where we see Cobb
and his partner Arthur they are the
extractors who use experimental dream
sharing technology to infiltrate their
targets subconscious and extract
information most of the time they work
for big corporations to steal
information from their Rivals they are
currently talking to a potential client
named Saito explaining to him that the
new dream sharing technology has
rendered thoughts of vulnerable to theft
the duo as the experts in this domain
extend an offer to safeguard Saito
against these threats Cobb explains that
when one is asleep there mind is
vulnerable to attack as a result he
offers to train saito's mind to
subconsciously defend against extractors
to protect whatever Secrets he may be
hiding however Saito brushes off their
idea and leaves saying that he'll think
about it later on Cobb and Arthur walk
outside to a gathering they discuss the
whereabouts of saito's Secret Safe
revealing their mission to steal his
expansion plants and deliver the
information to an organization called
COBOL engineering and during this they
noticed Cobb's ex-wife Mal prompting him
to approach her Mal asks if he misses
her to which she responds that he can't
trust her anymore following this they
Retreat to a private room where Cobb
rigs its chair with a rope and lowers
himself out of the window asking Mao to
stay on the chair however she deceives
him by getting up from the seat causing
a near mishap despite the setback Cobb
successfully gains access to the room
below where he exchanges the contents of
saito's safe soon after he is
apprehended by both Saito and Mal who
have already taken Arthur hostage here
it is revealed that the three men are
connected to a portable automated
somnous and intravenous or passive
device that administers the
sleep-inducing drug somnacin keeping
them all asleep and enabling dream
sharing their sleeping bodies are
watched over by Cobb's other partner
named Nash within the dream Cobb shoots
Arthur before swiftly exiting the room
he takes cover and opens the envelope
only to discover its contents are
counterfeit meanwhile Arthur wakes up in
the apartment and instructs Nash to
awaken Cobb as things are getting
intense Nash tries to do so but when
Cobb doesn't wake up he pushes him into
a bathtub full of water this triggers a
flood of waves in Cobb's dream causing
him to finally wake up and for this
movie's commercials to be very
successful as the dream in saito's
mansion collapses all three men awaken
in the apartment Cobb forcefully
positions Saito on the floor urging him
to disclose information about his
expansion plan however Saito remains
unaffected revealing that they are still
sleeping revealing a Dream Within A
Dream indeed Saito Arthur Nash and Cobb
are all asleep in a train watched over
by a young boy named Tadashi who
monitors the time remaining on the
passive device shortly after Cobb Nash
and Arthur wake up and get off the train
while Saito awakens a little later that
evening Cobb is in his apartment when he
receives a call from his children it is
revealed that they are currently living
with their grandmother as it is unsafe
for them to be with Cobb they inquire
about his return to which Cobb responds
that his work prevents him from doing so
in an attempt to cheer up their mood
kaab assures them that he will send them
gifts however the conversation is
abruptly ended by his mother shortly
after Arthur shows up and the two opt to
escape somewhere else due to their
failed job for COBOL engineering just
before their departure Saito approaches
them holding Nash hostage this time
Saito has different intentions he seems
to be impressed with Cobb's skill in
layering dreams over top of one another
so he proposes the Cobb work for him
Saito signs Cobb the task of implanting
an idea into the subconscious of Robert
who is the son of saito's rival Maurice
Fisher the idea is to perform Inception
on Robert's mind the this is the exact
opposite of what Cobb has been
practicing Through The Years instead of
stealing information from someone's
subconscious he has to enter their mind
and change their thoughts in this
Mission Cobb has to manipulate Robert's
mind so that he dismantles his father's
company in exchange Saito promises to
clear Cobb's criminal record so that he
can return to his children driven by
desperation Cobb agrees without thinking
twice following this he and Arthur
travel to Paris to assemble a team for
the mission upon arrival Cobb meets with
his father-in-law miles a university
Professor who taught Cobb and Mal about
dream sharing and dream design Cobb asks
for the finest architect and Miles
introduces him to a student named
ariadne Cobb then imparts basic rules in
terms of dream sharing technology to her
including the concept of a totem a
personal object that verifies if it's
reality or a dream and a kick a forceful
jolt that awakens a dreamer after some
trials and training ariadne is tasked
with designing the dream's architecture
something Cobb refrains from performing
due to the interference of his
subconscious projection of his ex-wife
Cobb then travels to Mombasa to recruit
his old friend Eames who is a skilled
British forger he finds him at a bar and
extends an invitation to join the team
eems agrees but before that he alerts
Cobb to two men tailing him Cobb
identifies the Miss cobal operatives
likely aiming to apprehend him sensing
the danger Eames creates a diversion
allowing Cobb to escape however the bad
guys go after him resulting in a lengthy
Chase through the city streets at the
last moment Saito shows up rescues Cobb
picks up Eames and drives away in a
limousine after this Eames takes them to
a local chemist named Yusuf an expert in
somnocent he talks to him for a while
and eventually manages to convince Yusuf
to join their team meanwhile Arthur
takes ariadne into another dream and
introduces her to Concepts like creating
paradoxes such as the Penrose steps he
also reveals that Cobb's wife has
already passed away and her presence
exists solely as a projection with thin
Cobb's mind in the next scene Cobb and
his newly recruited team members
strategize to construct a three-tiered
dream with the final level containing
the implanted idea as the team prepares
over the next few weeks Arthur
familiarizes ariadne with the importance
of totem's personal small objects that
allow them to distinguish between
reality and dreams Cobb's totem is a
spinning top that topples in the real
world but keeps spinning in dreams after
learning of this ariadne designs a
partially Hollow Bishop chess piece as
her own totem which does nothing in
reality but says in her dreams the team
needs as much time as possible to
complete the job so they decide to
execute their plan on an international
flight from Europe to America which is
the longest flight I beg to differ Japan
is much longer one evening after their
work ariadne notices Cobb dreaming alone
in the workshop intrigued she connects
herself to his device and joins in his
dream moments later she finds herself in
an elevator descending through various
levels each representing his distinct
memories she heads to the lowest level
where she finds Mao sitting on a couch
upon spotting her Mal grabs A Shard of
glass to attack her but Cobb's timely
intervention rescue zaryani following
this ariadne and kabx hit the dream and
he explains that the reason he can't go
home is because of Mal's death as she is
rumored to have killed his own wife just
then Saito and Arthur arrive there to
convey the news that Maurice has died
because of this his son Robert will be
accompanying the body to the states in a
few days a few days later the team
boards the flight and sits with Robert
and is sectioned off first class cabin
there Cobb discreetly administers a
sedative to Robert's drink initiating
the team's entry into a shared
three-layer dream with him in the first
level's Urban setting the team abducts
Robert but they are unexpectedly
attacked by his well-trained and armed
subconscious projections Saito sustained
several injuries due to gunfire but the
team somehow manages to make it to their
Hideout shortly after Cobb realizes that
experts have fortified Robert's
subconscious against extraction attempts
seeing saito's deteriorating condition
Eames contemplates killing him so that
he can awake in the real world however
things aren't that simple this time
because Yusuf sedatives are so powerful
that if they die they'll be sent
a world of infinite subconsciousness
faced with this limitation the team
resolves to proceed with their plan
Eaves then impersonates Robert's
grandfather Peter adopting an alternate
will as the idea to dissolve the company
Eames tries to provoke Robert saying
that his father loved him and wanted him
to build something of his own meanwhile
ariadne confronts Kaaba about the
control he has over his own subconscious
prompting Cobb to finally admit his
inability to keep Mal out of his
thoughts he divulges that he and Mao
entered into limbo during dream sharing
experimentation undergoing almost 50
years in a single night due to the time
dilation with reality at one point smile
refused to return to reality so Cobb
performed an Inception on her to
convince her despite returning to the
real world Mal continued to believe that
she was still dreaming and that they
must die to wake up however she refused
to leave without Cobb because she loved
him so much tragically on their wedding
day she committed the unthinkable and
framed cob compelling him to follow suit
failing to prove his innocence Cobb left
his children behind and fled the country
with the hideout in danger of being
infiltrated the team places Robert Navan
and sedates him before driving off they
then prepare to enter the second level
dreamed by Arthur while Yusuf steers the
van away from the pursuing projections
within the second layer of the dream
Cobb meets Robert in a hotel and says
that he is there to protect him as
someone is trying to access his mind he
helps Robert remember that he's been
kidnapped and leads him to a hotel room
where the rest of the team regrooves
Cobb also persuades Robert that he has
been abducted by Peter who wants to stop
the dissolution plan when Robert is
convinced Cobb suggests that they enter
Peter's dreams to uncover the truth
about the safe's contents so that he can
decide for himself Robert consents and
the team delves into the third dream
Lair this time Arthur remains behind to
watch over them and to give them a
synchronized kick when necessary the
third dream is set in snow-covered
mountains where Robert's safe is heavily
guarded in a Mountainside fort in order
to divert the guard's attention the
team's splits up Cobb teams up with
ariadne aims proceeds solo well Robert
and Saito has sent them out inside to
access the safe as Yusuf remains control
of the vehicle he is soon cornered on a
raised Bridge faced with no alternative
he plays music to alert Arthur to the
imminent kick before he reverses the van
off the bridge as the van plummets in
midair there is a loss of gravity in
Arthur's dream the impact also
translates into the third level of the
dream with a mere 10 seconds before the
van submerges into the water signifying
three remaining minutes in his second
dream for kick synchronization Arthur
tries to think of a solution ah goddamn
Nolan's in her complicated plots
similarly in the third dream Lair
there's an hour's time remaining amid
the urgency ariadne discloses the
quickest route to Infiltrate The
Fortress to the rest of the team amidst
all this saito's health continues to
deteriorate the group manages to enter
the main room housing the safe while
Cobb and ariadne keep a watch from a
sniper's angle struggling against his
injuries Saito lies incapacitated
coughing blood as Robert heads forward
upon nearing the safe Mouse suddenly
appears from behind despite sensing the
impending danger Cobb is unable to fire
at Mal and as a result she shoots Robert
instead moments later Cobb comes to his
senses and shoots Mal following this
altercation the team rushes towards the
safe seeing Robert dead Cobb deems the
mission of failure however ariadne
suggests descending to one more dream
Lair into limbo in order to bring Robert
back although it is a tough decision
with almost a disastrous consequences
they have no choice but to agree after
this Cobb accompanied by Ariana delves
further into another dream in limbo
ariani discovers a crumbling cityscape
built by Cobb and Mao during their 50
years of shared existence there not long
after they find Mal who again tries to
convince Cobb that this realm is their
real home in response Cobb admits that
he incepted the idea into her mind that
limbo wasn't real so that she would
agree to wake up and be with their
children Mal however persisted in her
belief that reality was a dream unlike
what Cobb had intended while they talk
Ariana and he finds Robert in limbo and
improvises a kick by pushing him
prompting him Awakening in the third
dream after this Robert accesses the
safe only to discover his ailing father
confined to his bed in his final words
Maurice tells his son to live life on
his own thus concluding the Inception in
the next scene the van drops into the
water triggering the kick in limbo the
synchronization of kicks pulls on
ariadne and she calls for Cobb to join
her he instructs her to get going as he
needs to find Saito who has perished in
the third dream and has entered the
limbo with this arianny along with the
other team members leap off the side of
the building and ride up through the
layers of the dream back to reality
meanwhile cobwashes ashore and is
dragged into the Mansion owned by a
wealthy old man the very mansion that
appeared in the film
scene this elderly man turns out to be
none other than Saito Cobb reminds him
of their Arrangement and tells him to
come back the scene then cuts and we see
all the dreamers wake up on the airplane
while Saito makes a phone call the plane
lands in Cobb's home country and he
nervously moves through the Customs
process with security scrutinizing his
passport and eventually permitting him
to pass without any problems Cobb's
father then greets him and drives him
back to his residence where his children
reside upon reaching home Cobbs spins
his totem to check the reality but when
he sees his children he chooses not to
observe the results and instead Embraces
them subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching